[Music]
I'm Julian Virginia I'm a writer and
philosopher essentially mostly working
freelance and we're here at how light
gets in
why do you think if you do think that
ideas and be thinking are important
today
well Harry yeah there's always a problem
I think philosophers look you ask anyone
what they do they tend to exaggerate its
importance
either philosophers it's very easy for
them to do that you know historically
we've had this privileged place in
society as a in the sages and the Guru's
and the wise people
so actually I'm always a bit worried
about over talking up philosophies wrong
but actually as a matter of fact I think
it is important it's important not as a
dispenser of wisdom and insight that the
world needs to thankfully gobble up and
say how well done now we understand the
world better but it's a kind of a
dimension of the cultural conversation
which i think is often missing because
now wherever you look whether we're
having debates about national identity
technology human enhancement equality
etc etc the environment all these issues
have vast philosophical assumptions and
ideas behind them which require
unpicking and discussing you know you
can't solve the climate crisis unless
you have some sense so if you know
what's at stake what matters and how
future generations comparing their
interests to present ones etc etc so I
just think that the philosophy is often
the unexamined aspect of a lot of big
issues but it's an important one and do
you think it should be like a sort of a
duty for philosophers to talk about
politics or to get involved with
politics well not necessarily politics I
think the and I also would defend the
right of some philosophers just to
pursue their their pure research in any
subject area there are some corners of
it which really you know they're only of
interest directly to people in that
field and you don't know what's gonna
happen in the long run that's the point
I mean it may turn out to be useful for
other people it may not but if you start
off by saying no no we're only going to
support people who do things which are
clearly relevant I think the problem
there is you're prejudging what relevant
is and you're prejudging what what
I happen so you need a broad canvas for
sure having said that though I think
that yes there is a kind of a
responsibility a kind of collective
responsibility if you like for people
engaging in philosophy to try and you
know join up what they're thinking with
those broader public debates it's about
I think they say participating in the
broader cultural conversation it's not
about offering your your wisdom in that
way not necessarily politics though I
mean politics is one dimension of it you
know it's Quadra sley we have this thing
now in Britain which is called the
research excellence framework which is a
way in which University departments are
judged according to the quality of their
work and their funding depends on this
and it used to be just about research
and now we also assess for the impact on
society and since philosophers have been
doing that it's really interesting to
look at these case studies they have to
write to justify their work and you have
philosophers working in health care
working with in in the arts working
along historical archive projects and so
on there are all sorts of ways which
philosophy joins up with culture
politics is just one of them and you've
written more recently about the
situation in Britain with brexit and how
philosophy can help in that sort of
situation or with a more divided nation
or yeah well III I'm not quite sure how
much philosophy can help sometimes you
can diagnose a problem more easily than
you can treat it right I think there are
various issues around the breaks it
brought to the fore which I think are
deeply problematic just one is I think
how we understand democracy actually
because you know this whole brick sit
debate part of the toxicity of it is
that there are a whole load of people
claiming they're the only democratic
thing to do is to basically do what one
referendum on one day said we should do
now the reason that's mistaken is not
because the result was incorrect
from a point of view of someone like me
it was a remainer it was the wrong way
of doing anyway so democracy the short
answer to this is that democracy this
pure form was never a good idea frankly
in that sense call me an anti Democrat
when Plato and Aristotle criticized
democracy they were correct because what
they were criticizing was a system in
which you basically asked of the people
what they think and majority opinion
wins and that's the end of the debate
obviously a stupid thing to do because
people aren't necessarily informed
enough to know the full situation but
also it creates division it also means
there's no long term rule of law because
what the people want today is what you
must do and if they want something
different tomorrow it's a recipe for
chaos democra made democracy work by not
making it pure democracy we had a system
whereby government is accountable to the
people which means that we can kick them
out if we don't like them and we choose
the ones we think are heading in the
right general direction and the whole
point about successful democracies is
that they are an ableist to negotiate
difference lasts the whole point
referendums and pure democracy is
actually about taking away the
possibility of negotiating difference
because basically the winner takes the
spoils so I think people got to think
hard about you know the failure of this
process or brexit has shown how it is
utterly disastrous I think the democracy
is about enacting the will of a majority
in any given day democracy is about
negotiating the different views of the
population that's what makes it work but
do you think it necessarily will lead to
chaos getting democracy in these sort of
platonic or ancient Greece yeah chaos or
tyranny or both probably tyranny
actually because that's a more likely
outcome because if every other situating
you government by the majority would in
political philosophy and physical theory
people say they distinguish between
democracy proper as they call it and
majoritarianism majoritarianism is just
the government of the majority over the
minority which leads to kind of
oppression it leads to the minority
feeling disenfranchised even almost
leads and taking that their rights being
taken away now I I think that that's
nice to think that majority isn't really
democracy I think that's not true I
think what George Hill is Amir's pure
democracy and what we want is something
else it's kind of inevitable
you know III if you take the theoretical
objections to pure democracy that they
stand up I think you know and I think
it's quite evident that look anywhere
around the world where democracy has
worked it hasn't worked by empowering
the majority to do what they want
irrespective of the interests of the
minority it's been a system in which
there is an understanding for a start
that whoever wins governs for all not
just the people who elected them that's
kind of going out the window right
people yell now people are being
expected to uuuu we've elected you as a
bricks in person you must speak for us
and you sod the remainders and vice
versa I was elected on a remain platform
so I'm not going to think about about
them it's it's inherently device if I
think to go for that pure form of
democracy but is that the system of
democracy or humans well humans are part
of the system of democracy I don't think
you can sort of distinguish them it's
the humans to the extent that we have
conflicting and different desires and
preferences and values it's a fact about
human society that there is that kind of
diversity we're not going to all agree
and it's also perhaps something to do
with human nature that generally
speaking people are reluctant to
compromise on what they think is most
important to themselves okay so the
inbuilt a human nature aspect of it is
that there's a diversity of opinion and
the kind of reluctance to compromise on
that then the system aspect of it is how
does the system deal with it and I think
the problem with a democracy of the kind
that majority wins a majority takes all
is that it doesn't do anything to
counter those two problems it doesn't
help us to deal with a diversity of
opinion it doesn't help us deal with the
fact that people have reluctant to give
up their their their views or their
positions when democracy as it is works
is precisely because having been elected
a government then seeks to do something
which gives something to all sides it
gives more to the majority sure they
want but it gives something to the
others as well and it and it manages
that diversity of opinion and can we
look at any philosophical traditions to
get over these sort of barriers of
either like reluctance to give up our
own ideas or accept difference of
opinions well I think we can look to our
own speaking as a Western European we
can look to our own traditions actually
around that I think we have a strong
tradition of you know the important of
reasoned debate and of argument and
there's quite a lot of yeah theoretical
work which has been practically
important about dealing with purity of
values and basic liberal ideas our
Liberty which allow different so there's
a lot of resources within our own
culture but I think that it's also
helpful to have that balanced a bit
because I think that if there's a
weakness in our culture it's this become
very individual focused and we tend to
always emphasize the rights and freedoms
of the individual and then always kind
of assume that anything that sort of
diminishes those is a very strong burden
of proof on it and it somehow kind of
bad or regrettable I think if we look to
some sort of non-western traditions if
you look at say Confucian ethics in in
China and also sort of it sort of
everywhere in the Far East to be honest
then what you really find is that there
there is more of an understanding of the
self as being embedded in society so who
you are yes you have your individual
value and dignity but you can only
really understand who you are as
understanding yourself as someone who
exists in social relations to others and
what that kind of way of thinking does
is people think that's a kind of an anti
liberty and freedom position it it
needn't be and it doesn't have to be but
what it is is it's just contextualizing
individual freedom and liberty and in a
way it's making explicit something which
we already know we already know that
although we value individual freedom and
liberty we can't just do what we want if
it harms others and so forth but we did
have a very limited narrow definition of
what that harm is physically harming
someone and so forth if we look at
cultures which have a more of a emphasis
on the importance of social harmony and
so forth it sees that when when we
ourselves as it were demand less of our
own individual rights
not because we are just subsuming our
identity to the whole or something or or
create look for going along with this
collective it's not about that it's
actually about a more honest recognition
that for anyone's have their individual
liberty there needs to be a kind of a
proper accommodation of everyone else's
to so a greater soar other focus i think
i'm is something that we can glean a bit
more from non-western traditions so the
lessons you've taken from sort of
non-western traditions such design your
work how the world thinks how do you
think we can take them on board do you
think that sort of the individuals in
the west has gone too far that we can
sort of recognize difference different
traditions how how do we then
incorporate it has it affected like
yourself like your own opinions or how
you've led your life yeah i mean how you
learn and incorporate from other
traditions is an interesting one i think
one thing you have to recognize a couple
things one has to recognize one is the
cultures are very complicated things and
there's a whole kind of ecosystem is a
philosophical ecosystem with a value
ecosystem and you can never kind of like
simply pluck out a value or an ideal
from another culture and like plant it
in your own soil and expect it to
flourish in that way you know in the
same way the horticultural analogy is
quite good there you know if you just
take someone from a different
environment put it in other it won't
grow or it might take over only only
very few plants actually you know fit in
very well so i think you've got to
recognize the fact that we are where we
are we have a kind we have the culture
we have and that's a product of our
tradition in our history and and there
be pointless to simply try and copy what
anyone else in the world is doing even
if we thought it was the best system but
the more hopeful note is this whenever i
talk about my book I always end up using
the same quote from a guy called Tom
Casillas who's a fantastic comparative
philosopher and he says words to the
effect of if you want to understand
cultural difference including for the
Safa chol difference don't think about
binary opposites or either ORS think
rather that what's background in one
culture is foreground in another and
vice-versa so I use this kind of
metaphor
like a mixing desk or graphic equalizer
if you like the kind of thing we had on
olds if you're a certain age which which
you're not the old stereos had all the
little dials of the treble the base for
living might be in a recording studio
you record all the instruments each one
has its channel and when you're trying
to create the final mix you turns things
up and down depending on what you like
the sound to be well I think if you look
around the world the values list if you
like political and ethical values this
is kind of the same everywhere the
difference is how far they turn up and
down we've turned up things around
individual liberty 211 right in in
cultures like China for example social
harmony is just turned up higher than us
it's our scale everyone values social
harmony but it gets drowned out a lot
the time from individual liberty so I
think the best way to learn is this you
look at how other cultures do things
differently and you don't never go and
try and copy it but what you do is you
go back and look at your own cultural
dial and you say okay so having made
that comparison have we got our settings
right have we turned up individualism
too much if so it's not about rejecting
individualism it's just sort of like
dialing it down a bit
all other other things we need to dial
up I think that's the way to learn and
it's it's um it's tricky because there's
no algorithm for this people are
algorithms how should you live what's
the ideal Society the traditional
thought in the West has also had that
model and Marty I said I think
criticized it very very well that the
way we set up I think about politics is
we imagine the ideal society and then we
try and get as close to it as possible
and I think the send persuasively argues
that's nonsense you start from where you
are and then you make your adjustments
that's the way to go and making those
adjustments is not about requires
judgment and this is what I think
philosophers are very uncomfortable with
but a lot of people uncomfortable with
you can't just say this is the right
answer you've just got to use your
judgement about what the right level is
and in a democracy of course you use
that judgment in a way you have to try
and bring people along with you persuade
them and so do you think that we can
teach philosophy in a different way
to make people feel empowered to be able
to make those adjustments well I think
that obviously you won't be surprised to
think that I think that philosophy
should have a greater role in the
education system but in my ideal world I
wouldn't necessarily introduce
philosophy as a separate subject I I
think the greatest potential is for
people to look at the philosophical
dimensions and all the subjects we
already study because that has various
advantages first of all it makes it more
real and applicable straightaway you're
not teaching this weird abstract subject
and then having to make people see the
relations between things rather you know
you can talk about identity character
personality through literature or
something you can understand you know
I'll get about truth and objectivity
through history and philosophy of
science and so forth so III would like
to see that way of bringing philosophy
into the education system and I think if
it if we'd had that kind of system sure
people would be more empowered to sort
of see those for the Safa call ways of
thinking and to incorporate them more
into their board of debate because I
think it is missing from so many things
I mean there's their philosophical
dimensions or all sorts of important
political and ethical debates and
they're often kind of just ignored and
from your work in how the world thinks
how do you go about doing your own
research like how did you come to
research different cultures and
therefore well I mean Mike the way I
work is I'm not an academic and the
reason for that is that I'm my main
interest is in the horizontal on the
vertical if you like it's be an academic
these days you tend to have to choose a
fairly narrow field and go deep into it
which has its value for sure but I think
the problem is with everyone doing this
and going deep there's no reward in
academic life for joining the dots and I
think that that's what's often most
useful for people so my way of working
is to be a parasite upon those narrow
deep thinkers and to then but then try
and join the dots between them so I will
do some some reading on
particular areas and then I often do
always these days I do some interviewing
so I go and talk to people and sort of
like ask them the questions I want to
ask them and try and partly to test
whether when I'm making the connections
I make whether I'm getting them right
and then I also often tried to do things
which involve looking at some real-life
cases to see whether the application is
so when I was writing about personal
identity for example you know I spoke to
someone who changed gender
I spoke to identical twins was the
freewheel book actually but another
example of that I spoke to some llamas
who has supposedly reincarnated you know
and things like things like surreal
people says a combination of trying to
get some kind of real life kind of
grounding and experience some some book
learning and some interviews with
experts and in trying to join the dots
in a way that allow the subject to make
sense to people and to be applicable to
them and do you feel like you can get to
a point sis if you're studying sort of
Eastern traditions of philosophy so
anyone can have the world things can you
get to the point that you feel like you
can understand the philosophies even if
you're coming from a point of like a
Western individual what hasn't been what
no yes and no I mean I think that you've
always got to if we're going to be a
broad thinker and writer like I am you
should never kid yourself that you've
really sort of you understood everything
and in how the world thinks absolutely
not I mean I once make it clear that I'm
trying to get ways in I'm trying to I
was trying to identify some of the key
ideas which are enabled you to see the
most important differences the things
that make the dip these ways of thinking
importantly different to our own in ways
that we can learn from so I absolutely
don't think I've remotely cracked it at
all now I understand it but what I
understand something which gives me some
point of connection in some way and some
way of using that as a as a lens in
which to look back at my own
tradition but obviously there's there's
always so much more to learn and I there
about couple of people in the world who
can genuinely claim to be experts on
more than two traditions in philosophy
I'm not one of those two people and
where is your work taking you next well
I mean I the strange thing about writing
books is a bit like you know filmmakers
they're being interviewed about their
film going out in the cinemas and
they're already working on the next one
and so it's always a bit like that with
with books I'm quite long into a book
which I don't want to say too much about
because it's to keep things intrigued
but let me just give you the premise of
it to see it see what you think of it
which is that I over the years as
someone who's been very interested in in
religion although I'm an atheist I'm
always struck by this thing people say
which is that they say they don't
believe that Jesus Christ was a son of
God but they think he was a important
good moral teacher and really the book
I'm working on just asked the question
is that true so was if you take if you
don't if you take Jesus Christ is not
being Christ just being Jesus of
Nazareth do we find in him a strong and
compelling set of moral teachings or
actually not I won't tell you the answer
I'd have to wait and one final question
so we're arts and ideas festival I
wondered if there's any films artists
songs song lyrics that particularly
inspire your own philosophy or you just
personally yeah well quite a lot
actually I often use literature music
film in my books to illustrate things I
think that the arts can you know get us
to attend to things in ways I think are
actually genuinely philosophical because
I think philosophy in the Western
tradition is often meant to be about
argument and arguments a big role but I
think all the best philosophy is also
about the very very careful attending
and I think there are lots of examples
of that perhaps just to give one is of
all the films the Coen Brothers
I think are fascinating they are very
very diverse but I think in all those
films I think you see some very
important
I'd say philosophical insight into into
ethics and morality actually what it
means to be a good person and what the
difference is between a good person and
a bad person and I think if you look at
a lot of Coen Brothers films you you you
get kind of three archetypes which keep
recurring there's the kind of there's
the complete sadist or the compressors
completely outside or the moral domain
who just has got a moral bone in their
body sort of embodiment of evil but then
you have the kind of like the the pure
in heart if you like who actually often
quite simple straightforward people
they're not philosophers but they're
just good and decent and then you have
these people who are who are corrupted
by degrees they're not evil wicked
people and yet something things happen
chain of events they allow themselves to
be corrupted and often do really bad
things and you know without sort of
going into detail about and that the
film's do this is in different ways so
many of their films are in a way showing
us rather than arguing for us important
truths about what it means to be a good
person in a world where there's so much
temptation to do wrong and one more and
you have spent a lot of philosophy and
philosophers in your time and if you
have to go on holiday with any
philosopher alive or dead who would you
pick and where would you go
who would I go okay well actually
because I one of my most unusual
projects to date is I've written a book
about David Hume but at the moment is to
be published in Korean and not in
English we hope it we publish in English
and and part of the way that book was
structured was we went on a journey with
a philosopher so I followed in the
footsteps and I did David Hume and so
David Hume seemed to me to be great
company I think he's a great philosopher
so I think I'd go for a tour of France
and Paris with David Hume and see what
he would think about what had changed
between now and then and we'd certainly
have to get him to sort of reconsider
some
very remarks he made about on race which
have sort of stained his reputation I'm
pretty sure he would be ashamed and
embarrassed by those and would recant in
an instant because he was a philosopher
who always responded to evidence but
it'd be good to do that so yeah I'll go
to France with him more camembert for
you thank you very much for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institute of arts and ideas at iai
TV
you